trois diplomates européens déclaré
indésirable par moscou des employés des
ambassades de suède de pologne et
d'allemagne qui ont participé à une
manifestation de soutien naval nice non
autorisée par les autorités du pays
en visite dans la capitale russe josette
borel n'a pas tardé à réagir
le chef de la diplomatie européenne
condamne fermement ces expulsions et
demandent qu'elle soit reconsidérée
josette borel a appris pendant sa
réunion avec sergueï lavrov que trois
diplomates européens allait être expulsé
de russie
il a fermement condamné cette décision
et a rejeté les allégations selon
lesquelles il aurait mené des activités
incompatibles avec leur statut de
diplomate étranger les pays concernés
ont également réagi à l'annoncé de
moscou la suède évoque une expulsion
complètement infondées si d'un de ses
représentants
la chancelière allemande pointe du doigt
une décision injustifiée et le chef de
la diplomatie allemande promet de ne pas
en rester là
de son côté la france s'est également
positionné à l'issue d'un conseil de
défense franco allemand sur la sphère
navalni je les dis je condamne avec la
plus grande fermeté du début à la fin ce
qu'il s'est passé de l'emploi zone ment
aux conditions terribles du retour la
sanction est la condamnation est
aujourd'hui l'expulsion des diplomates
allemands polonais suédois qui ont été
décidées par la russie depuis retour de
la vanille en russie les autorités ont
dénoncé à maintes reprise ingérence de
plusieurs pays européens et des états
unis dans ce qui constitue une affaire
interne au pays